* Scheuergeräusche *
Die Fritteuse ist leicht verstopft.
Es ist seltsam,
dass es nicht rauskommt.
Oh, was machst du?
Bist du wahnsinnig?
Nein, Schatz!
Eine Posada in der Pampa Uruguays.
Vier Monaten nachdem Ruedi Althaus
auf- und davonging
kommt auch Ehefrau Susanne
im neuen Daheim an.
Ah, cool. Aber kalt.
Für ihr Bauprojekt muss das Paar
auf 14 m2 zusammenrücken.
Schön, schön.
Hochsaison in Kanada.
Das Motel aus den 60er-Jahren
bringt Familie Almeida
viel mehr Arbeit als erwartet.
Wir können auf Dauer nicht
sieben Tage pro Woche arbeiten.
Ihren Wunsch nach mehr Ruhe
müssen die Auswanderer
aus dem Kanton Zürich zurückstellen.
Und an der Nordsee steht der Imbiss
von Sacha und Brigitte Kunz
kurz vor der Eröffnung.
Ich hoffe, dass viele Leute kommen.
Bis das Geschäft mit Würsten
und Pommes frites angelaufen ist,
bleiben Noemi und Timo
bei ihrer Grossmutter.
Ihr werdet bald hier sein.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Two double rooms. 99,
and 20 discount - do you remember?
Yes, I do.
Im Motel von Familie Almeida
sind übers Wochenende
alle Zimmer ausgebucht.
Nicht ohne Grund: Es ist Oktoberfest.
A lot of people here.
Für einmal ist Beatrice
ohne ihren Mann Josef unterwegs.
Hi, Sandra. How are you?
Sie hat sich mit Nachbar Charles
und einer Freundin verabredet.
Beatrice will wissen, was die
Veranstaltung so besonders macht.
* Lüpfige Schlagermusik *
Das Oktoberfest in Tatamagouche
ist das grösste seiner Art
im Osten Kanadas.
Hi, there.
Zwei Tage lang
zelebrieren die Menschen
aus der Provinz Nova Scotia
bayrische Bräuche.
Es ist toll. Mal etwas anderes.
Es ist schön, mal rauszukommen.
Es ist toll.
Ein paar Freunde ... Tipptopp.
(Alle) Hey!
(Mann am Mikrofon)
Wunderbar! Wunderbar!
Der nächste Morgen:
zurück in den Alltag,
zurück ins Motel.
Ich beginne mit Abziehen.
- Ich öffne.
Eins ums andere, um zu lüften.
Oder hat sie bereits? Okay.
Die Zimmer müssen für neue Gäste
wieder hergerichtet werden.
Doch eine der beiden Reinigungskräfte
hat sich krankgemeldet.
Jemand ist ausgefallen. Die andere
schafft allein nicht 16 Zimmer.
Das ist zu viel.
Man läuft ... ich weiss nicht
wie oft, hoch und runter.
Mit der Wäsche, dann fehlt ein Glas.
Zu zweit kann man sich aushelfen.
Aber allein geht das nicht.
Es ist auch anstrengende Arbeit,
das darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Da muss man fit sein.
Es ist fast wie einst in ihrem
Bed and Breakfast in Turbenthal.
Mia, mia?
- Ja, im Drei.
Wo bist du?
- Im Drei.
Der Manager muss auch noch ran.
Bea, wo versteckst du dich?
- Im Drei.
So.
So weiss man, wieso und was man
am Ende des Tages verdient.
Eigentlich wollten die Almeidas
in Kanada kürzertreten.
Aber das Motel
fordert sie Tag für Tag aufs Neue.
* Sanfte Musik *
An der Nordsee
im Imbiss von Familie Kunz
ist alles bereit für die Eröffnung.
Klappt super.
Fast alles.
Du musst mit dem Daumen
draufdrücken.
Wo?
- Du musst die Luft ...
Bei der Öffnung.
Hier meinst du?
- Ja.
Ah, dass er saugt.
- Genau.
Es geht nicht.
- Doch, doch.
Schaust du mal?
- Geht es nicht?
Nein, er saugt nicht.
Das sind Anfangsschwierigkeiten.
* Er lacht. *
Kommt's?
Jawohl, super. Bravo. 100 Punkte.
Moin.
- Hallo.
Einmal Pommes mit Mayonnaise.
- Gerne.
Dankeschön.
Der Job im Imbiss
ist für die Baselbieter neu.
Oh ja, Schatz. Gib mir das Geld.
- Ja.
Das ist noch in der Tasche.
Ja, das haben wir vergessen.
Brigitte,
eine gelernte Krankenschwester,
arbeitete Teilzeit
in einem Sportgeschäft.
Sacha verkaufte als Vertreter
Signalisationstechnik.
So, Pommes mit Mayo.
Dankeschön.
- Gerne.
Die ersten eigenen Pommes frites.
Neun Monate nachdem die Auswanderer
den Imbiss in den Ferien
entdeckt hatten.
André, hi.
- Grüss dich.
Hi.
Sagte ich doch: Sonnenschein.
- Ja, du hast ...
Nachbar André
darf natürlich nicht fehlen.
Er hat
seine ganze Familie mitgebracht,
samt Eltern und Grosseltern.
Hi.
Hi, Ali.
Alles Gute,
und das ist von uns allen.
Dankeschön. Das ist lieb.
Schatz, einmal Frikadelle.
- Einmal Frikadelle, der Herr.
* Lachen *
Jetzt könnt ihr arbeiten.
- Wir machen weiter.
Weiter geht's!
Frikadelle? Frikadelle?
Einfach mal zum Test.
Beiss mal rein.
- Pass auf!
Heiss.
- Ist es gut?
Mit ihnen haben wir viel getestet.
Würste. Wir haben sie
Verschiedenes probieren lassen.
Sie waren gegenüber den Produkten
sehr kritisch.
Aber es zeigt sich,
dass wir auf dem richtigen Weg sind.
Wer hat noch nicht
und möchte noch gerne?
Oma möchte auch eine Frikadelle.
Auch eine Frikadelle?
Schaust du?
Die Pommes
kannst du ruhig fertig machen.
Pommes mache ich.
Ja.
Können wir uns da hinsetzen?
Ja, nehmt Platz, wo ihr wollt.
Die ersten Gäste
sind schon mal zufrieden.
So darf der Tag gerne weitergehen.
Guten Appetit. Danke.
Schön, seid ihr hier.
Zum gemeinsamen Start ins neue Leben
wollen Ruedi und Susanne Althaus
ein Bäumchen pflanzen.
Der Boden hier ist sehr zäh.
Wenn er trocken ist, ist er zäh.
Und wenn er nass ist ...
ist er lehmig.
Darum ist es ein Ausprobieren.
Ein Ausprobieren,
wie auch unser Projekt.
Noch mehr?
- Nein, ist gut.
Die beiden anderen lassen wir drin.
Ich muss jetzt dann
mit unserem Kater raus.
Er wäre jetzt langsam so weit,
dass er die Umgebung
auskundschaften will.
Gut.
So, auf dass es gedeihe!
* Antreibende Musik *
Seit der Ankunft in Uruguay
vor zwei Tagen
hat Kater Ghöri
das Bett kaum verlassen.
Bist du halb am Schlafen?
Ich gehe mal raus mit dir.
Schauen wir, wo du zu Hause bist?
Schau mal ...
Hier riecht es ganz anders.
Aus dem lieblichen Emmental
in die fremde südamerikanische Pampa.
Schau mal. Gehst du auf den Boden?
5 ha Land warten jetzt darauf,
erkundet zu werden.
So weit darfst du mal gehen.
So weit.
Passiert nichts.
Hier drunter darfst du nicht.
Ich kann dich nicht hervorholen.
Nicht hier drunter.
Gehen wir rein?
In Menschenalter
wäre unser Kater bereits 55.
Mit 55 von einem ...
... sicheren Ort,
den man schon so lange gekannt hat,
an einen anderen Ort zu kommen
ist stressig für ihn.
Auch Susanne
muss sich erst eingewöhnen.
Ganz im Gegensatz zu Ehemann Ruedi.
Für ihn ist die Schweiz
schon ganz weit weg.
Die letzten Jahre hatte der gelernte
Bauschreiner einen Bürojob beim Bund.
Wir waren ein wirklich gutes Team.
Ich hatte eine gute Chefin.
Aber den Bürostuhl
vermisse ich echt nicht.
Dem trauere ich noch nicht nach.
Findest du den Weg wieder zurück?
Schauen wir mal.
Schatz!
Ja?
- Kannst du ihn mal rufen?
Wo ist Butz?
- Schau, dort.
Butz. Wo ist Ghöri?
Wir bleiben einfach mal hier.
Wäre dies ein Ort für dich?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Kater Ghöri geht es wie Susanne.
Sie brauchen beide noch etwas Zeit.
Früher Nachmittag an der Nordsee.
Und plötzlich
ist die Hafenterrasse voll.
Mit Mayo und Ketchup?
Tomatenketchup?
Ketchup auch.
Pommes frites für 2.20 Euro,
die Currywurst 3.50.
Mit kleinen Beträgen
müssen Sacha und Brigitte
ihren Lebensunterhalt bestreiten.
So, guten Appetit.
Backfisch gibt's dort oder dort.
- Wir haben keinen Fisch.
Wir haben nur Pommes und Würste.
- Dann eine Pommes, bitte.
Mind. 100 Würste
wollen sie am ersten Tag verkaufen.
Hi.
- Hi.
Gerne zwei Currywürste
und dazu eine Pommes mit Mayo.
* Drollige Spielorgelmusik *
Ja.
Hier, Schatz.
Einmal Pommes Spezial
und sechs Chicken Nuggets.
Currywurst, Pommes, Mayo.
2.10 Euro.
Frikadelle, Pommes? Hotdog?
Mit was? Ohne nichts? Gar nichts?
Bitteschön.
Dankeschön.
In Kanada macht sich Familie Almeida
ans nächste Projekt.
Heute wollen sie einige Reklametafeln
für das Motel erneuern.
Machen wir ein grosses?
- Ja, wenn du einverstanden bist.
Du kannst Robin den Akku geben.
Rund 15 Schilder hat der Vorbesitzer
rund um den Ort Tatamagouche
aufgestellt.
Wie gut in Schuss ist das Holz?
Da macht man fast mehr kaputt.
- Draufmachen? Halt es mal hoch.
Wie ist die Grösse?
Haben wir gut gemessen?
Es ist okay, oder?
- Hol eine Schraube.
Hältst du es?
- Ja.
Ich brauche die Leiter.
Ich bin nicht so gross.
Möchtest du nicht erst
ein paar festmachen?
Josef will das neue Schild
direkt auf das alte schrauben.
Doch das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Du hast nicht richtig eingehängt.
- Ich sehe es.
Jetzt sehe ich es. Oh, ui, ui, ui.
- Pass auf!
Es muss irgendwie rein.
- Ganz zusammen und dann ...
So?
- Ich sehe es nicht.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es gut.
- Ich würde sagen, ja.
Auf diese Art von Werbung
können die Almeidas
auch im Internet-Zeitalter
nicht verzichten.
Einen Grossteil des Geschäfts
machen sie mit Gästen,
die ohne zu buchen
direkt vorbeikommen.
In diese Richtung
gibt es noch ein kleines Motel.
Weiter unten auch,
aber dann kommt bis Pictou nichts.
Vom Motel aus sind das etwa ...
... 45 Min.
Da kommt nicht mehr viel.
Es ist wichtig, dass man das weiss.
Spätestens jetzt wissen sie es.
Okay, kann ich die Leiter nehmen?
- Ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es ist okay.
Es gibt etwas her.
Dann geht es weiter
auf den Bauernmarkt von Tatamagouche.
Die Almeidas wollen sich so gut es
geht ins Dorfleben integrieren.
Du bist eine Zwetschge.
So und ... Wie läuft das Geschäft?
Ziemlich gut.
Dankeschön.
Will sonst jemand diesen?
Ein paar Monate erst
lebt die Familie in Kanada.
Aber für sie ist jetzt schon klar:
Sie wollen bleiben.
Ich finde es toll hier.
Aber wir sind noch ...
... nicht so richtig aufgenommen.
Es gibt noch Vorbehalte.
"Schön, dass du hier bist,
aber du hast erst eine
temporäre Aufenthaltsbewilligung."
Es liegt vielleicht daran,
dass man sich erst behaupten muss.
Das ist ungewohnt.
Aber das habe ich
nicht immer im Hinterkopf.
Eher die Arbeit.
Ich frage mich eher, was ist,
wenn sie nach zehn Jahren sagen,
wir dürfen nicht bleiben?
Das soll nicht sein, aber ...
- So darfst du nicht denken.
Das ist einfach etwas merkwürdig.
* Sanfte Musik *
Der Schachtring aus Beton
ist für den neuen Brunnen.
Kannst du drei
von den Hölzern bringen?
Zusammen mit Susanne möchte Ruedi
die Wasserpumpe verkleiden.
Wohin?
- Jedes in je eines.
Hier?
Und eines vorne in der Mitte.
Die Posada in Uruguay
ist nicht ihr erstes Projekt.
Schon das Einfamilienhaus im Emmental
hatten die beiden eigenhändig gebaut.
Ich bin der Hilfsarbeiter.
Ich schaue, ob er's richtig macht.
Brauchst du das Klebeband noch
oder nimmst du frisches?
Oben im Container -
wenn du rankommst -
halb rechts, äh, in der Mitte rechts
gibt es welches.
Dann kann man frisches drankleben.
Das eigene Wasser zu haben war ihnen
schon beim Kauf des Landes wichtig.
Unser Projekt ist,
das Grundwasser abzupumpen.
Das hat den Vorteil,
dass es nichts kostet.
Wir müssen nichts bezahlen.
Und ... Die Wasserqualität
ist so weit so gut.
Fünf Gästehäuser, ein Restaurant
sowie den Swimming Pool
wollen sie mit diesem Wasser
versorgen.
Du könntest hier obenrum durch.
Schau, dass du hier unten ...
Bisher trieb Ruedi die Bauarbeiten
allein voran.
Es ist nun viel angenehmer.
Ich muss nicht mehr selber rennen.
Wenn man z.B.
nicht ans Klebeband denkt,
kann man den Gehilfen schicken.
Du weisst schon, was du machst?
- Nein. Aber ich mache es.
Eigentlich ist die Holzverarbeitung
sein Fachgebiet.
Aber Ruedi ist einer,
der sich zu helfen weiss.
Das ist der Druck,
weil der Tank höher ist.
Für die Wasserinstallationen
hat er einen befreundeten Spengler
um Rat gefragt,
im Internet recherchiert
und sich Tricks bei den Handwerkern,
die den Brunnen gebohrt haben,
abgeschaut.
Juhu.
Kommen wir so rüber?
Ähm ja. Wenn ich etwas kippe schon.
Kann ich runterlassen?
- Nein, weiter nach vorne.
Von der Krankenpflegerin
zur ersten Hilfsarbeiterin.
Susanne
wird noch manche Gelegenheit haben,
in diese Rolle hineinzuwachsen.
Infusionen
sind auch eine Präzisionsarbeit.
Aber hier ist es grober.
Das sind grobmotorische
Präzisionsarbeiten.
Das ist nicht so schlecht.
Nimm die Hölzer weg.
Keine Handschuhe.
Für den Moment ist es gut.
Aber nicht für dauernd.
Da gibt's noch Mani- und Pedicure.
Das hast du gut gemacht.
- Ja, gut.
Räumen wir zusammen?
- Zusammenräumen.
* Entspannte Musik *
* Möwenkreischen *
Abendstimmung auf Platte 1.
Das Pommes-Gewürz ist echt gut.
- Das habe ich gut ausgesucht.
Ich habe es ausgesucht.
- Nein, nein.
Gut 10 Std. standen Brigitte
und Sacha an der Fritteuse.
Wir hatten heute einen guten Tag.
Für den ersten Tag.
Es hat auch Spass gemacht.
Ich bin froh, mich hinsetzen
zu können nach den vielen Stunden.
Stehst du nie mehr auf?
Die Müdigkeit kommt dann,
wenn ich zu Hause bin.
* Entspannte Akkordeonmusik *
Noch aber ist nicht Schluss.
Sie müssen die Grillküche reinigen.
1 1/2 Std. putzen - das gehört nun
zu den täglichen Aufgaben.
Wie war der erste Tag?
- Ja, super.
Ja, es war alles gut.
- Morgen früh in alter Frische.
Morgen wieder in alter Frische,
so wie es steht.
Tschüss.
- Schönen Abend, danke.
Es ist ein Traum.
Schau mal, das ist wirklich genial.
- Besser kann man es nicht haben.
* Entspannte Akkordeonmusik *
Und dann Kassensturz:
662 Euro haben sie eingenommen.
Ja, wir haben gut gearbeitet.
Was sagst du?
Ich denke auch.
Das denke ich auch.
Das wird nicht jeden Tag so sein,
aber ...
Wir wissen,
was man im Jahr hier macht.
Was man in diesen acht Monaten
erreichen kann.
Und das ist kein schlechter Betrag.
* Scheuergeräusche *
Jetzt muss Sacha nur noch
das Öl in der Fritteuse erneuern.
Doch irgendetwas
stimmt nicht mit dem Auslauf.
Es ist schon ziemlich viel draussen,
aber es fehlt noch ein Stück.
Es ist seltsam,
dass es nicht rausläuft.
Oh, was machst du?
Bist du wahnsinnig?
Nein, Schatz.
- Es läuft nicht raus.
Weil oben das Loch verstopft ist.
Es gibt ein Lied,
aber ich singe es nicht.
Das WC ist verstopft.
Der Abfluss will einfach nicht.
* Drollige Musik *
Bouillon mit Einlage.
Diese Arbeit würde ich
nicht jeden Abend aushalten.
Ein letzter Versuch
mit dem Draht von oben.
Und, bist du schon weiter?
Es ist schon mehr drin.
Hast du es geschafft? - Ja.
Ja, wir haben es geschafft.
Muy bien.
Auf der anderen Seite
des grossen Teichs
läuft bisher alles nach Ruedis Plan.
Eineinhalb Jahre
gibt er sich für den Bau.
Dann wollen die Schweizer
hier zahlende Gäste beherbergen.
Als erstes Gebäude
will der 53-Jährige
das Wasch- und Werkstatthaus
fertigstellen.
Ja, es kommt mir zugute,
dass ich diesen Job, Schreiner,
einmal gelernt habe.
Von daher ... ist das praktisch.
* Entspannte Musik *
Das neue Daheim der Auswanderer liegt
unweit von Colonia del Sacramento.
Die Stadt hat knapp 27'000 Einwohner
und ist wegen ihrer historischen
Altstadt ein Touristenmagnet.
Da müssen wir da rüber.
Susanne hat sich mit Auswanderungs-
beraterin Alex verabredet.
Sie gibt ihr Tipps, wo sie in Zukunft
für den Alltag einkaufen kann.
Die kennt ihr, oder?
- Nein.
Ich kenne sie nicht. Hello.
Was kaufe ich für heute Abend?
Susanne möchte für Ruedi
etwas Besonderes kochen.
Ah, ein Milanesa könnten wir machen.
Ähm ...
Así para hacer o ya empanadas?
Bei dieser Gelegenheit kann Susanne
auch ihr Spanisch testen.
In der Schweiz hatte sie regelmässig
Privatlektionen genommen.
Sino, aquí es lo mismo pero ya
empanadas. Prontas para hacer.
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Panada kommt von Brot,
d.h., dass schon Ei und Semmelbrösel
drauf sind.
Empanadas.
- Genau. Ja.
Okay. Hoy empanadas.
En el futuro lo hace ella.
Ich verstehe
je nachdem wie schnell sie reden.
Mit den Ausdrücken ist es schwierig.
Man muss ... etwas reinkommen,
und ich bin noch völlig überfordert.
Es gehen mir 1'000 Dinge
durch den Kopf.
Aber das ist erst der zweite Tag,
an dem ich hier bin.
Ich darf noch gestresst sein.
Also, es ist einfach etwas viel.
Aber es kommt schon gut.
Das sind alles sehr liebe Menschen.
Perfecto.
- Muy bien. Pronto?
Sí!
- 4.35.
Du kommst auch ohne mich klar.
Es ist halt einfach bequemer.
Wenn sie muss, dann muss sie.
- Ja, das ist so.
Die Frage ist, wann sie Lust hat,
es zu müssen.
Muchas gracias.
- Muchas gracias.
Ciao, hasta luego. Gracias.
Ciao.
- Gracias.
Mama, da oben ist ein Wespennest.
Ich hätte es easypeasy
runterholen können.
André, auf keinen Fall!
- Nicht unbedingt.
Sonst fliegen uns die Wespen
um den Kopf.
Wie bei "Die Tribute von Panem"?
- Genau.
Familie Almeida erkundet in Kanada
ihr riesengrosses Grundstück.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
der See war letztes Mal grösser.
Direkt vor ihrer Haustüre
beginnt die Wildnis.
Hast du den Biber gesehen?
Alles angefressen.
Auch hier überall Spuren.
Sophie, warte!
- Geh den Ohren nach.
Warte!
* Entspannte Musik *
Es ist ein Tag,
wie er schöner nicht sein könnte.
Stünde den Almeidas
nicht ein Abschied bevor.
Schon morgen fliegt Mutter Beatrice
zurück in die Schweiz.
Ich muss ein paar wichtige Sachen
zusammensuchen.
Wie jedes Jahr im Herbst
will sie Anis-Guetzli backen
und auf Märkten verkaufen.
Das ist ein Superbusiness,
und ich backe gerne Guetzli.
Wir wissen nicht,
wie lange wir es noch machen.
Vielleicht möchte später
Sophie einmal mitkommen.
In der Schweiz
kann man in kurzer Zeit
noch ein paar Franken dazuverdienen.
Es ist alles eingespielt,
es funktioniert einwandfrei.
Darum machen wir es noch einmal so.
Die zusätzliche Einnahmequelle
hat aber auch eine Kehrseite.
Zehn Wochen
ist sie von der Familie getrennt.
Das wird manchmal sicher hart,
so allein zu sein.
Ich bin mir das
nicht mehr so gewohnt.
Jose ist immer fest an meiner Seite.
Jeden Tag.
Das ist ungewohnt.
Auch die Kinder ...
Das ist starker Tobak.
Es sind zweieinhalb Monate.
Das ist nicht einfach so:
"Ach, was soll's."
* Wehmütige Musik *
Beatrice und Josef
sind seit 23 Jahren ein Paar
und waren noch nie länger
als ein paar Tage getrennt.
Ich verdränge es.
Mir ist mulmig zumute.
Ich hoffe,
ich werde viel Arbeit haben ...
... damit ich nicht oft
daran denken muss.
Aber es wird gehen. Gehen müssen.
Aber es macht mich natürlich
traurig.
Ich mag das Fräulein.
Ja, ist so.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich schaue zu ihren Gartenzwergen.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Tag 10 am Küstenimbiss.
Noch die beiden Pommes,
dann ist fertig. - Ja.
Schliessen wir.
Und Pommes mit Ketchup.
Danke.
- Guten Appetit.
Ich schalte den Grill aus.
- Ja, ja.
Für einmal
schliessen die Kunzens früher.
Denn endlich
kommen auch die Kinder nach Dorum.
Jetzt ist es Zeit.
Für uns, für die Kinder.
Länger hätte es nicht gehen dürfen.
Sechs Wochen haben Sacha und Brigitte
ihre Kinder nicht gesehen.
* Wehmütige Akkordeonmusik *
Tschüss! Schönen Abend.
Ja, danke.
Ciao, bis morgen. Grüsse!
Nur noch ein paar Minuten,
dann kommen die Timo und Noemi
am Bahnhof in Bremerhaven an.
Welcher? Von Cuxhaven?
- Nein.
Von Bremerhaven?
Hast du den Autoschlüssel
mitgenommen? - Nein.
Ich habe ihn steckenlassen.
- Echt?
Wenn wir kommen, ist das Auto weg.
- Pech gehabt.
Das wird passen.
Dann laufen wir nach Hause.
- Du hast ihn mir nicht gegeben.
Vor lauter Stress
liess ich ihn stecken.
Das ist ein gutes Viertel.
(Lautsprecherdurchsage)
Ankunft N S 2 nach Bremerhaven.
Hier kommt er.
Wie abgemacht.
- So gut. So gehört es sich.
Bravo!
Reise überlebt? Kommt erst raus.
Hoi, Dicker.
Alles gut?
- Ja.
Noemi und Timo
sind vor mehr als 10 Std.
mit ihrer Grossmutter Susanne
im Baselbiet aufgebrochen.
Eine Reise durch ganz Deutschland.
* Sentimentale Musik *
Jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
Super. Alles gut?
Was hat sie eingepackt? Steine?
- Nein, Kleider.
Sicher nicht nur Kleider?
- Kleider und Schminke.
Ah, die Schminke wird es sein.
- Nein.
Steht das Auto noch hier?
- Ja, es steht noch.
Es hat sich sicher abgeschlossen.
- Das wäre geil.
* Lachen *
Ja, es ist geschlossen.
- Sicher nicht.
Timo, erschrecke mich nicht.
Erzähl nicht solche Dinge.
Gut, einsteigen. Kommt.
Es geht nach Hause.
Ins neue Zuhause.
Ich finde es komisch zu sagen
Zuhause.
Ohne euch
war es noch kein richtiges Zuhause.
Oh mein Gott.
Im neuen Daheim in Dorum erwartet
Noemi ein frisch renoviertes Zimmer.
Sehr schön. Das gefällt mir.
Warum ist das Licht so schwach?
Kann man es ändern?
- Nein, es ist nicht so hell.
Die Lampe.
- Das dachte ich mir.
Auch Timo hat neue Möbel bekommen.
Und hier den Schreibtisch?
Ja, hier machen wir
den Schreibtisch hin.
Dann hat er ...
Sind es drei Schubladen?
Nein, hier sind es zwei
und auf der Seite noch eine.
Das war auch eines
zum Zusammenbasteln.
Ja, das ist doch gut.
Es sieht so ganz anders aus -
mit den Möbeln.
So habe ich den Eindruck.
Aber es ist schön.
Bist du zufrieden? Gefällt es dir?
- Ja.
Noch etwas an die Wände.
Endlich wieder vereint.
Ich habe euch vermisst.
- Wir dich auch.
Fehlt nur noch der grosse Sohn Kevin.
* Gemütliche Akkordeonmusik *
Feierabend in Uruguay.
Gut 10 Std. schuftete
Auswanderer Ruedi auf der Baustelle.
Ehefrau Susanne
hat etwas früher Schluss gemacht
und bereitet das Abendessen vor.
Es ist wie im Skilager.
Aber für den Moment geht es.
Hast du mir den Deckel?
Ja, aber ich muss erst noch ...
Ich hasse Gas.
- Hast du die zweite aufgedreht?
Nein. Kannst du mir das machen?
- Natürlich. - Das wäre lieb.
Aus einem 7-Zimmer-Haus
in einen Wohncontainer.
Für ihren Traum mit der Posada
nehmen die beiden einiges in Kauf.
Hier musst du aufpassen.
Also ich spiele gern,
aber lieber mit Kerzen.
Hier drehst du auf und zu.
Und dann entsprechend richten.
Mehr oder weniger.
Man kann die Finger wärmen.
* Susanne lacht. *
Und jetzt schnell in die Tasche.
Nach 30 Jahren Beziehung
stürzen sich Ruedi und Susanne
noch einmal ins Abenteuer.
Härzli.
- Auf uns. - Auf uns.
In der Weite der Pampa sind sie sich
so nah wie schon lange nicht mehr.
Grundsätzlich
sind wir ein gutes Team.
Wir kennen
unsere Stärken und Schwächen.
Gewisse Dinge
mussten wir auch lernen.
Ja, das kann man
nicht von Anfang an.
Teambildung braucht Zeit.
- Ja, ja.
Die brauchten wir auch.
Vielleicht
haben wir teils zu wenig gesprochen.
Darunter hat die Teamarbeit
ein wenig gelitten.
Sie hat gelitten, darum hatten wir
eine Beziehungskrise.
Ehe- und Familienalltag ...
die Kinder, die ausgezogen sind ...
Man muss sich wieder ...
auf das Team Ehepaar konzentrieren.
Ich lernte andere Frauen kennen.
Ich bin dann ausgezogen.
Das war effektiv so.
Für mich war das ...
ein Weltuntergang.
Für die ganze Familie.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Weil wir uns doch noch
etwa so fest gern hatten,
machten wir eine Therapie.
Also Therapie ...
Wir suchten professionelle Hilfe.
Wir hatten einen guten Psychologen.
Darum konnten wir
wieder zusammen reden.
Ohne diese Unterstützung
wären wir heute nicht hier.
Das ist so.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Auf uns.
Auf das Leben.
- Ja. Und dass wir hier sind.
* Wohliges Seufzen *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Mama,
ich möchte mit dir in die Schweiz.
Ich weiss, Schätzeli,
dass du das am liebsten möchtest.
Armes Schätzeli. Komm zu mir.
Ich bin bald zurück.
Es geht schnell vorbei.
Heute reist Beatrice ab.
Dem achtjährigen Robin
fällt es besonders schwer,
seiner Mama goodbye zu sagen.
(Lachend) Ja ...
In zweieinhalb Monaten
ist sie zurück.
Dann werde ich auch sagen:
"Das ging aber schnell."
Gell.
- Ja.
Hat's geklappt?
In zweieinhalb Monaten
hole ich dich wieder ab.
Ich freue mich jetzt schon.
Mehr als auf das Bringen.
Nur noch 4 Std., dann sitzt Beatrice
im Flieger in die Schweiz.
An der Nordsee
richtet sich Brigittes Mutter
in ihrer neuen 3-Zimmerwohnung ein.
Ohne die Enkel
in der Schweiz zu bleiben
wollte sich die 70-jährige Susanne
gar nicht erst vorstellen.
Der Job, den meine Tochter
und ihr Mann haben,
ist sehr arbeitsintensiv.
Die Kinder wären allein
oder beim Wagen.
Wenn die Schule wieder beginnt,
wird das ...
... etwas schwierig für die Kinder,
den Hund und die Katze.
Darum sagte ich,
dass ich zumindest vorläufig
mitgehe.
Ich bleibe vier Monate hier.
Und dann schaue ich weiter.
Susanne wohnt im ersten Stock,
Schwiegersohn Sacha
und Tochter Brigitte
mit den Kindern im Erdgeschoss.
Katze, bleib dort!
Nein, Roxy. Nein.
Ja, guten Morgen.
Wow, dass du schon auf bist!
- Schon seit einer halben Stunde.
Ehrlich?
Hast du wirklich ausgeschlafen?
Ich glaube schon.
Kann ich heute waschen?
Ja, logisch darfst du.
Hier waren wir letzte Woche.
Es gab einen schönen Bericht.
Super, das musst du einrahmen.
Das ist gut.
Sagst du mir,
was ich noch einkaufen soll?
Ein bisschen Salat,
damit wir Salat essen können.
Dusch das hast du noch?
- Ja, ja.
Noemi sucht es aus.
Glace hat's noch im Tiefkühler.
Vielleicht kommen wir um 22.30 Uhr,
vielleicht um 21.30 Uhr.
Vielleicht erst um 23.30 Uhr.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Können wir gehen?
- Ja.
Tschüss zusammen.
- (Alle) Tschüss.
Kaum sind die Kinder da, müssen Sacha
und Brigitte schon wieder weg.
Der Imbiss wartet.
Ich habe noch Capri Orange dabei.
Die Arbeit fordert ihnen einiges ab.
Bis zum Saisonende in drei Monaten
haben sie keinen Tag frei.
Das reicht vorerst. Brötchen?
Timo, die ganze Beige muss weg.
Mama hat damit angefangen.
Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Schau mal.
Unmöglich. Zusammenlegen.
Kante auf Kante.
So bekommst du eine schöne Beige.
Dann kannst du es reinlegen.
- So?
* Entspannte Akkordeonmusik *
Am Flughafen in Halifax
heisst es Abschied nehmen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Tschüss, Mama. Viel Spass.
Danke schön. Schaut gut zu euch.
Ja, machen wir.
Ich bin stolz auf dich.
- Danke.
Oh, Robin.
Sie kommt bald wieder.
In zwei Monaten.
Schau gut zu dir.
- Sicher.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Ich vermisse Bea schon sehr,
bereits jetzt.
Und es sind erst 5 Min. vergangen.
In der nächsten Folge
startet Beatrice in der Schweiz
mit dem Verkauf ihrer Guetzli.
Sophie! Komm rein!
Die Zeit allein in Kanada fordert
Ehemann Josef mehr als gedacht.
Ja, ja. Ich bin für alles zuständig.
An der Nordsee
kommt Grossmutter Susanne
zum ersten Mal an den Imbiss
und wird gleich eingespannt.
Ich brauche Kleingeld.
- Je zwei? - Je einer.
Und Tochter Noemi
muss sich im Training
im neuen Cheerleading-Verein
bewähren.
In Uruguay erfüllen sich Ruedi und
Susanne einen langgehegten Wunsch.
In einem Jahr sind es Maschinen.
Aber das Leben auf der Baustelle
hinterlässt bereits erste Spuren.
Wir haben uns dafür entschieden, wir
gehen nicht nach drei Wochen heim.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt,
# chöme nümme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
ufder Suechi fürnes nöis Dahei.
# Si göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020